Robert Pattinson is doing a little
backtracking the star the upcoming the
Batman reverse course in an assertion
he's made a couple of times in recent
months that Batman isn't actually a
superhero
Pattinson first put forth his bat
opinion during a conversation with the
New York Times in October of last year
well it's understandable that his
opinion would be a touch controversial
among fans it's also kind of tough to
argue with and it illustrates the
interesting approach the actor seems to
be taking to portraying the character he
said Batman's not a hero he's a
complicated character I don't think I
could ever play a real hero there's
always got to be something a little bit
wrong Batman's morality is a little bit
off he's not the Golden Boy unlike
almost every other comic book character
there is a simplicity to his worldview
but where it's it's as strange which
allows you to have more scope of the
character okay that's all well and good
but Pattinson really run into trouble in
December during a sit-down with today at
that time the star doubled down in a big
way doesn't count you need to have like
magical powers news all we can do is
speculate us of whether Pattinson has
ever heard of the many many superheroes
who don't technically have any powers of
course when he finally did reverse track
on this controversial opinion Pattinson
did so in typically cheeky fashion
speaking with Time Out's the after
explained that he thought it lost a role
when the fact that he was being eyed for
it by Warner Brothers was publicly
leagues he was obviously excited when he
was cast
but ever since landing the coveted part
the star has been the subject of plenty
of fan complaints some of them it seems
just don't think he's cut out for the
role and those not a superhero remarks
didn't do anything to win them over
Pattinson is quite aware of that fact
and he explained to time out that if he
had simply brushed up a bit more on his
DC law he wouldn't have said what he
said that said he didn't exactly back
all the way off his comments according
to him I wasn't educated about the
subject people got very angry about it
it's bizarre I still can't understand
the arguments okay he's a superhero I'm
sorry
the next headline button cinema tracks
Batman is in fact a superhero he takes
it back
despite the insane level of scrutiny
that comes with being cast as a Caped
Crusader
Pattinson is still beyond excited for
those fans to actually see the film he
said I'm only worried about whether
people like it when it's done right now
people can think what they want it's the
coolest thing ever I still can't really
believe it we suppose this backtracking
concert is standing with the fans but
many of them will forever disparage
button stands casting purely because of
his involvement with The Twilight Saga I
start superhero stuff right now what if
I'm not to hero what if I'm the bad guy
we've pointed this out on several
occasions before but since a lots of
fans seem to keep missing it we're going
to go ahead and do it again button Sun
is a far better actor than his stint in
the Twilight movies would suggest for
recent evidence look no further than his
incredible performance in the lighthouse
if you're still not convinced we submit
2017 s good time a harrowing crime drama
from the safty brothers who just turned
in another minor masterpiece with uncut
gems
puttan son's desperate turn as a crook
trying to scrounge up the dough to
spring a simple-minded brother from jail
must be seen to be believed
Pattinson also delivered a stunning
performance in the 2018 sci-fi drama
high life in which he portrayed one of
two survivors of a doomed deep-space
mission what was saying here is that
Pattinson has spent his entire post
Twilight career absolutely crushing it
in extremely challenging roles that's
why were so certain that Pattinson is a
perfect choice to play Batman of course
the proof will be in the finished
product the Batman is currently before
the cameras and deleted to hit the big
screen on June 25th 2021
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos but
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and to
the bail so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you